Welcome.
I'm going to try to cover
the whole of the global
environmental crisis, the entire
globe, at a rate of
about 1 slide every
23 seconds.
The idea for the Unconference
came from hearing about this
exciting new way of doing
conferences, that's happening
in sort of techie circles.
I wanted to bring that
creativity and that idea of
listening to your
audience into an
event with young people.
This is the problem you face
if we look at the world
population going back to when
humans appeared from
mitochondrial DNA, probably
around 130,000 years ago.
We're wacking through at
an incremental rate.
This is a staggering rate
of population growth.
Why do we need science media
coverage in the first place?
Why do we need science out
there on TV, in the
newspapers, on the internet?
The fastest mass extinction the
planet has ever seen on
the fossil record.
Probably by a factor
of 10,000 fold.
And you're in the middle
of it right now.
There'll be lots of kids in your
school like lots of kids
that I've encountered who
don't really want to do
science after 16.
They're not really
interested in it.
No matter how hard people like
me try to get them interested.
They're not.
So is it fair that we force
them to study science?
Are you really going to teach
those kids science?
Or are you going to build in
them a resentment towards
science because they were
made to study it
until they were 16.
Does it really matter if the
public don't understand the
full nitty gritty of scientific
research?
And if it's all slightly wrong,
is it the job of the
media to be educating the
public in any case.
Is that really their role?
In the next three years,
chopping down rainforests will
release as much carbon dioxide
as every single airplane
ticket ever sold since the days
of the Wright brothers up
to the year 2025.
The problem with land mines is
they are a very cheap and
effective deterrent.
You don't want someone to
go into a certain area.
You lay landmines.
You just scatter them
from an aircraft.
You lay landmines.
The first few people go in, they
get limbs blown off, and
they don't go in again.
But it's not good enough
to just state
that science is important.
You have to explain why.
So your challenge this afternoon
is, you need to
convince me that everybody needs
to study science because
I'm not convinced.
Costs around 768 grams of CO2
per dollar spent on GDP.
You've got to get that
down to six.
Hooke's Law.
Have you all done Hooke's Law?
All right, what's the point
of Hooke's Law?
You get some springs, you hang
some weights off it.
It's probably incredibly
boring, right?
And Hooke already did it.
With most science there is
an ethical dimension.
Look, just because you find
something fun doesn't mean
you're learning anything.
The science is made
so simple as to
actually making it wrong.
Adults, my generation,
have no solutions to
any of these problems.
We have got so much knowledge.
We have so many resources.
Yet we still act like
stupid idiots.
We import oranges from
South Africa.
We don't have to look
after the Earth to
make our lives easier.
We have to look after
the Earth to make
our kid's lives easier.
Our lives are going to
be much easier if we
don't look after it.
If you want the genuine
information then you go read
it from a journal, in
the first place.
As opposed to getting it from
the main stream media.
To simplify it so that regular
people can understand it.
And it's not all
medical jargon.
The problem with hydrogen is
that it's explosive, it's
highly reactive.
Surely this comes to the
responsibility of the person
designing it, because they
could create a very silly
experiment.
Even if you do have to simplify
something so that the
general public can understand
it, that doesn't mean it
should be less accurate.
L'Oreal was founded by a chemist
over 100 years ago.
And so science is absolutely
fundamental to
everything that we do.
The challenge with doing such
an unstructured event with
young people is that they're
not used to being given the
floor in such an open way.
And apart from anything else
that can be really daunting.
So we've added in a little
bit more structure.
If you can't hear what's going
on, do put up your hand.
If 99% of people
think it's not.
Then you've proven
that it's wrong.
The challenge for us has been
learning how to do this
entirely new type of event as
we're going, using e-mail and
Twitter with young people in a
live event has been a bit of a
steep learning curve for us.
Well, not really...
It fits a well known
stereotype.
And it is largely true.
You see the sports personnel who
are on TV all the time and
they're not scientists.
They haven't done the science.
You don't see the
science side.
[INAUDIBLE]
on the object.
I say that it's more that
we've been made to feel
dependent on it.
What about all the
medical devices?
You've got all the equipment
in hospitals that use
electricity to save lives.
You'd be going backwards.
You would actually just go
back to being a caveman.
No, I'm not saying getting rid
of all electricity, I'm just
saying that there are certain
things that we are really made
to feel that we need, a lot
more than we actually do.
We hope to feed back some of
the themes from the day
directly to Parliament to give
them a flavour of what young
people think of the answers to
the sorts of questions that
we've been debating today.
You cannot get rid of basic
scientific literacy.
We already have so much
scientific illiteracy in the
world and it's really
not helping.
It's someone's job themselves to
question what they see and
what they hear and
what they read.
And if people don't do that,
then it's simply a
free-for-all, anyone could say
whatever they like, especially
in the media.
So that's why we want people
to be better informed about
science in general.
And that's key, we thought about
critical thinking, that
needs to be compulsory to
everyone from earlier.
Because it's difficult to get
work experience and not many
children are exposed to what
worker insights would be like,
it's quite hard to aspire for
a career which you really
don't have any information
about.
If you look at how science
actually works, then you look
at the stuff on the GCSE
specification, they're
completely divorced
from each other.
But the one thing we can do is
make sure that the kids, the
younger generation, make the
choice that they really want
to, like make sure there's
opportunities to become
scientists, that is if they
want to become scientists.
We want to make GCSEs a lot
more challenging to
differentiate between the real
future scientists and the
people who are quite good.
The idea of a beef tax, which
despite unpopular opinion
based from people who like
steak, we think that this
would actually work
quite well.
Because for a start, cows
produce a large amount of
methane and that contributes
to global warming.
At the same time, there
are lots and lots of
other options for food.
We want to be consistent with
the specifications.
We only want to change them if
something has gone deeply,
deeply wrong.
Because if you just
- Thank you.
Sometimes when things like
polymers are discovered, it
creates whole new industries
which leads to millions of new
jobs eventually.
It also leads to jobs outside
of science as well.
If you're attached to the
government, you speak for the
government, it doesn't have to
be this huge negative thing
fighting global warming.
It can be...
It can mean maybe that Britain
tries to become the biggest
exporter of environmental
technology.
We don't have to see it as like
a huge job that we have
to fight against.
We can see it as a way to make
money and a way to actually
get richer as a whole
group of people.
So you need to educate
people, and not just
young people, but adults.
Because a point that we raised,
someone like Professor
Hugh Montgomery who is saying
that it's now our
generation's job.
He doesn't have to suddenly say,
that's it, I'm not going
to do anything anymore,
it's your job now.
You're still a generation, well
I'm looking at people
sitting lower down, that's still
very much prominent in
everyday life.
So everyone needs
to be educated.
And that would largely now be
done through the media because
we can't tell you all to
go back to school.
Another main issue is
environmental investment.
It's very different from
anything else we've ever done.
It's hard to get a consensus
on anything.
Very, very tough.
I think it's worth the trip
down from Yorkshire.
I can now see why politicians
have a tough time.